[Music]
on this Thursday night alarming Trend
people aren't trying to find policy
Solutions they're trying to find a
revolution Global News investigates a
surge in violent threats against
politicians
RCMP officers charged with manslaughter
there's no way that this process should
take this long the case against the
mounties accused of killing an
indigenous man six years ago
hurdles in health care why so many
Women's medical issues are still taboo
plus didn't see that coming
the unexpected twist overshadowing
Groundhog Day in Quebec
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with a glimpse into a
chilling Trend Canada's Federal
politicians facing a torrent of what are
called violent rhetoric and intimidation
tactics Global News has obtained
documents through access to information
that detailed dozens of internal threat
assessments prepared for senior
government leaders threats made to
politicians of all stripes and threats
that grew in number and intensity during
the pandemic along with extremist
ideologies and a tangled web of
conspiracy theories our chief political
correspondent David Aiken explains
what's in those threat assessments David
well Donna the documents obtained by
global news are heavily censored but
they do reveal that between January and
August of last year Federal security
agencies compiled 71 different threat
assessments threats made against Federal
politicians I think that's a significant
number and it does mean that people are
worried among the threats one made last
marched on The far-right Social Network
gab that said foreign affairs minister
Melanie Jolie should be executed for
treason my wife has received so much
horrific material directly to her social
media account that we pierre-polyev and
other MPS were quote targeted by online
hate speech and threats during the
Convoy protests of last winter and
Public Safety Minister Marco Mendicino
targeted by an Instagram user who
threatened to shoot him because of
federal gun control proposals
well I never laugh it off and I'm less
worried about me I am very concerned
about my family and I'm concerned about
all of my colleagues again on both sides
of the of the aisle
are you doing an Alberta
Traders
this is something that's you know fairly
new to Modern Canadian politics it's
kind of this rise of what I would call
like an anti-politics people aren't
trying to find policy Solutions they're
trying to find a revolution
the threat assessments were prepared by
Canada's integrated terrorism Assessment
Center which works closely with csis
Canada's spy agency it says these
threats prompted by ideologically
motivated violent extremism are a
significant risk obviously I'm extremely
concerned about the alarming rise and
threats which we're seeing not only
online but in person indeed a security
official wrote pervasive online toxicity
can lead to real world dangers in low
security situations there's a spectrum
here going from people who are just
fundamentally unhappy to people who
actually detonate bombs and there's no
guarantee that people will move across
the Spectrum
but I think there's the real possibility
that they will if something isn't done
about it in fact the commission that's
reviewing the decision to invoke the
emergencies act last winner is expected
to make recommendations that will help
police security agencies and governments
right across the country identify and
combat these new and dangerous types of
threats Donna okay David Aiken in Ottawa
thank you
the leader of the block quebecois says
he thinks Canada's newly appointed
special representative on combating
islamophobia should be fired e Francois
Blanchette believes Amira El gawabi
doesn't understand what he calls the
desire for secularism in Quebec the two
met yesterday but that obviously hasn't
changed his mind or that of other
quebecers Global's Felicia Perillo
explains what's behind the controversy
this is a bad choice by the Prime
Minister who making such a choice kind
of
destroyed the possible credibility of
the function it's a controversy that
Quebec's political leaders agree on
Mr Trudeau has just endorsed contempt
for quebecers says Premier Francois
Largo referring to the Prime Minister
once again expressing his support for
his newly appointed special
representative to combat islamophobia is
I support Amira al-gawabi 100 the Prime
Minister told reporters in Ottawa one
day after calls for her resignation
began in Quebec I think Justin Trudeau
made the wrong I mean the wrong decision
at the center of the controversy a 2019
opinion piece Al gawabi co-authored on
Quebec's Bill 21 the controversial law
barring public sector workers from
wearing religious symbols on the job the
piece published in the Montreal Gazette
said in part unfortunately the majority
of quebecers appear to be swayed not by
the rule of the law but by auntie limb
sentiment Al gawabi apologized on
Wednesday I would like to say that I am
extremely sorry for the way that my
words have carried how they have hurt
the people of Quebec but the block
quebecois continues to call for her
resignation they crossed a line because
they don't just ask for the resignation
of Madame but they ask for the abolition
of the position itself and this is
something completely new and I think it
shows the true face of the black
quebecois the controversy comes just
days after the sixth anniversary of the
Quebec City mass shooting that killed
six Quebec's National Assembly passed a
motion demanding algowabi lose her new
job because of her old comments however
it's the federal government's decision
and Justice Minister David lametti says
we should give her a chance to do the
job now that she has now that she has
come out with with uh with apologies and
clarifications Felicia Perillo Global
News Montreal
a family in Prince George BC wants to
know why it took nearly six years for
charges to be laid against five RCMP
officers the case centers on the death
of Dale Culver an indigenous man in
2017. Constable Paul St Marie and
Constable Jean Francois Monet have been
charged with manslaughter three other
mounties face charges of attempting to
obstruct Justice tonight Culver's
daughter is speaking out and she has
lots of questions nithu garcha reports
it's the only thing that I have left of
my dad Lily speednemox is holding both
this necklace containing her father's
ashes and cherished memories close to
her heart will you smile
it was contagious you could make anybody
smile anybody laughed as she processes a
major development in the investigation
into his death
charges of manslaughter against two
officers and obstruction of justice
against three others who were accused of
telling witnesses to delete any cell
phone video it's an uneasy feeling to
know that the people who
in my eyes murdered my dad are still
working and having their jobs and
spending time with their family
according to Prince George RCMP four
officers remain on duty and one is on
administrative leave for reasons
unrelated to this incident
35 year old Dale Culver of both gitsan
and wetsuit in Nations encountered
police in July of 2017 following reports
of a man casing Vehicles Culver tried to
get away but after a brief struggle
pepper spray was used the father of
three struggled to breathe and later
died there's no way that this process
should take this long charges were
recommended by the province's police
Watchdog in 2020. First Nations have
known for a long long time
that we are subject to racism and uh
egregious Behavior by police services
across Canada why it took so long for
charges to be laid is a key question for
assembly of First Nations Regional Chief
Terry tigi who's demanding quicker
action to resolve other ongoing cases a
relative of mine ever Patrick who had
died in custody and many other cases
Jared loudness in in Campbell River
another what's it in man so certainly
many cases out there that are still
outstanding and as for why those
officers who've been charged in Culver's
death are still on duty the RCMP hasn't
made that clear speednemok says the
charges being laid feels like a
reassuring step in the right direction
it's definitely a lot for my whole
family however with the trial set to
begin March 14th it's also the beginning
of another long and difficult process
for the family
Global News Vancouver
there is a development tonight on
assisted dying in Canada the federal
government is delaying expanding the law
to allow people with mental illness to
choose a medically assisted death it was
set to take effect in March but mental
health Advocates worried there aren't
enough safeguards in place the Justice
Minister says there were concerns
doctors and hospitals weren't ready for
the change he wants to ensure everything
is in place before the program is
expanded
what we're doing with this deadline is
giving time
for whatever reason kovid or or or other
factors giving time to those those
provinces
faculties of medicine
Etc to internalize uh the the very I
think
positive guidelines that are given uh by
the expert committee and with the
subsequent work done by the federal
government and to allow everybody to be
on the same page uh when when we start
um
but a great deal of the work has already
been done in fact many people in those
communities uh feel that we're we were
ready to go in March 2023
a joint house senate committee is
studying the legislation and possible
safeguards as our provinces medical
schools and colleges trying to ensure
appropriate guidelines are in place the
conservative leader Pierre Palio
denounced the entire made legislation
today saying people with mental illness
shouldn't be getting government help to
end their lives
there is more evidence tonight of the
barriers women face getting medical
treatment called surveying the silence
the report gathered data from more than
two thousand albertans and it reveals
women are consistently dealing with
misinformation misdiagnosis inconsistent
responses and disjointed approaches to
their health care as many women know too
many things are still taboo including
menopause endometriosis and painful
periods Heather urich's West explains
from the age of 10 Violetta kandovsky
has dealt with debilitating pelvic pain
I wasn't believed for a long time and
the pain was really severe and my my
family didn't know a lot about it so my
mother just thought some women have
awful periods and that was it years
later kandovsky would finally learn she
has endometriosis the painful condition
impacts more than a million Canadians
and yet patients Will Wait an average of
five and a half years before they're
even diagnosed we know that 50 of the
population
are assigned female at Birth as women
it's still taboo to talk about many of
the health issues related to their
specific Anatomy according to a new
survey from the Alberta Women's Health
Foundation that taboo is putting the
health of women transgender men and
non-binary people at risk keeping them
from accessing help for a wide range of
issues things like polycystic ovarian
syndrome pelvic floor disorders even
menopause we certainly do have providers
in community particularly Family
Physicians that do have focused areas of
women's health and I think we need to
advertise that better and make sure
women have access to those providers but
access to Providers varies depending on
where you live in the Southern Alberta
City of Lethbridge for example where
there were once nine Obstetricians
gynecologists there is now only one
Beyond finding care of the survey also
found treatment Effectiveness is also a
major concern just 16 percent of women
seeking care for a perimenopausal
symptoms were satisfied while data
suggests 10 percent of women will stop
working because they're perimenopausal
or menopausal symptoms are so bad
Federal funding are research dollars to
women's health is not to the same level
uh in general and a lot of it has to do
with quality of life as much as life and
death and so it's harder to get funding
fixing the problem Advocates say will
take a combination of education and
investment and more women like kandovsky
willing to move beyond the taboo and
talk
Heather York's West Global News Calgary
countering Chinese aggression coming up
why the U.S is expanding its military
presence in Southeast Asia
the U.S is increasing its military
presence in Southeast Asia in hopes it
will help counter China's aggression the
agreement expands America's military
presence in the Philippines securing
access to four more bases there it also
completes the arc around China adding a
key link the Philippines borders two of
the biggest potential flashpoints Taiwan
and the South China Sea Jackson prosco
explains why the U.S is making this move
and how China is responding with Taiwan
under growing threat from China and
Beijing expanding its presence in the
South China Sea
the U.S is pushing back with the deal to
access four bases in the Philippines
part of a mutual defense treaty another
American toehold on China's doorstep our
goal is and always has been to promote
greater security and stability
throughout the region in response
China's foreign Ministry accused the U.S
of raising tensions and urged countries
in the region to avoid being compromised
by the United States
China should take this as a wake-up call
that it's not just that Americans are
getting fed up with its Behavior but
countries in the region are seeing the
bullying alarm has spread Beyond Taiwan
through Asia and around the world
there's no mistaking the Frantic pace of
China's military buildup and
assertiveness Beijing is substantially
building up its military forces
including nuclear weapons without any
transparency
it is attempting to assert control over
the South South China Sea
and threatening Taiwan
trying to take control of critical
infrastructure including in NATO
countries Where It All Leads is the big
unknown a four-star American General
recently penned a memo predicting the
U.S will be at war with China by 2025
just two years from now he wrote I hope
I am wrong it's our military's job to be
ready and you know I think there's a
tendency in the Pentagon these days and
in Washington to think that we can have
this Nifty form of deterrence well you
know what hard power matters though the
Pentagon has distanced itself from those
comments it's clear the U.S is not
sitting idly by preparing for an
uncertain future and an unfamiliar
adversary the Pentagon stresses that
American use of those bases in the
Philippines will be temporary not a
permanent deployment military planners
believe that flexibility will be
essential in any future conflict so too
is security for America's allies in the
region Donna
Jackson in Washington thanks searching
for survivors ahead the rescue efforts
after Russian missiles Pummel a
Ukrainian apartment complex
not everyone is struggling with
inflation and Rising costs oil and gas
giant shell raked in record-breaking
profits in 2022. the uk-based company
reported it made nearly 40 billion
dollars U.S that year that's more than
double its earnings in 2021 and the
highest profit in the company's 115-year
history Energy prices have surged
especially in Europe which faced
Russia's threats to cut off pipeline
supplies because of its invasion of
Ukraine and Russia launched a new
barrage of air strikes on eastern
Ukraine today
rescue crews work through the night
after missiles destroyed this apartment
building at least three people were
killed there are fears others may be
pinned under the debris more than a
dozen buildings were hit in the attacks
including a school and a health clinic
the city is home to a command center for
Ukrainian military operations and is the
staging ground for defending the key
city of bakmut
more than a dozen top officials from the
European Union met with Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski in Kiev
today it is their first Gathering since
the full-scale War Began they're
promising more arms money and sanctions
before the first anniversary of the
invasion EU Aid has now topped 73
billion dollars but the trading block is
still not fast tracking Ukraine's bid
for membership
and Global News will Air a special on
February 25th one year since the latest
Russian invasion of Ukraine there are
concerns in the UK about avian flu
spilling over into mammals after reports
the virus has been detected in otters
and foxes in England Scotland and Wales
a highly contagious and deadly form of
the virus known as h5n1 has been
ravaging bird populations around the
world for the last two years UK Health
officials say they're ramping up
surveillance and testing of animals
exposed to the virus the jump to mammals
could pose a growing threat to humans
though the risk remains extremely low to
date Canadian officials estimate more
than 7 million birds have been infected
by this strain of the virus
foreign
who could have predicted that next how
Quebec's Groundhog Day Celebrations took
an unexpected turn
[Music]
it's February 2nd and you know what that
means tomorrow is February 3rd okay yeah
yeah it's also Groundhog Day and there
seems to be an ever increasing number of
rodents predicting whether there will be
six more weeks of winter in BC Vancouver
Island's Violet saw her Shadow so six
more weeks of winter there Manitoba Merv
agrees although he's not actually alive
he's a plushie he has been wrong only
once in 30 years Ontario's Wireton Willy
was Shadow free he predicts an early
spring shubenacity salmon Nova Scotia
plus Lucy the lobster who maybe wants to
be a rodent but still looks a lot like a
lobster they both saw their shadows and
there is more in Quebec there's Fred the
Marmot his tale is worth the full Eric
Sorensen treatment
Punxsutawney Phil ladies and gentlemen
there are conundrums with Groundhog Day
who to believe Phil who saw his shadow
this year or wired and Willy who didn't
and how to interpret six more weeks of
winter that long cold forecast for
southern Pennsylvania would be like
global warming in Northern Canada what
day is this February 2nd
Groundhog Day and the film Groundhog Day
juggles the silliness with the profound
the weatherman who cannot escape the
repetitiveness of that day what if there
were no tomorrow even a reporter with a
groundhog puppet Ponders the existential
what if there is no tomorrow which
brings us to Fred Le Marmot seen here
last year Fred the Groundhog's shadow
makes a forecast every year in
valdespoire Quebec
so as always the town's folk gathered
the mascot danced and organizer Roberto
blonde kicked things off except
ions
say what Fred is dead
seems when Fred was checked recently
I mean it happens they live only 10
years or so here's 1973 Punxsutawney
Phil Lord knows how many there have been
since they began in the 1800s
so let the tradition continue said
London Calling for music music
[Music]
Curtis Mayfield's 70s Soul classic comes
to mind
but the truth is they played something
appropriate to cheer things up
[Music]
shoes
it was decided Fred would have wanted a
child to predict this year so a stuffed
Marmot was pulled from Fred's cabin
given to a youngster in Groundhog Garb
and held up to the bright Sunshine the
forecast well more winter less groundhog
Fred was the fourth groundhog in
valdespar's
next year they say there'll be a fifth
Eric Sorensen Global News
yeah oh Fred that is global national for
this Thursday I'm Donna Friesen
tonight's your Canada is the Bow River
in Calgary we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching Farah Nasser will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow and I will see you
Saturday for the new reality bye-bye
[Music]